you are now watching a special edition
of the press preview live from
buckingham palace a first look at what's
on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with a
journalist and author christina
patterson and former editor of ok
magazine and the sunday express martin
townsend
so let us see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the front of the observer pictures
our new king charles iii as he ascends
to the throne
reunited for granny reads the front of
the mirror as the duke and duchess of
cambridge and the duke and duchess of
sussex are pictured together for the
first time in mourning
the sunday times also leads with that
story with the headline warring
windsor's awkward troost honor the queen
the daily star also looks at the two
royal couple's reunion
reunited in sorrow reads the front of
the sunday telegraph
and this same story is also on the front
of the sun on sunday their headline all
for one
the sunday express follows this story
too with the headline together for
granny william hands olive branch to
harry
and peace for gran reads the front of
the sunday people
and we are joined tonight by journalist
and author christina patterson and
former editor of okay magazine and the
sunday express martin townsend welcome
to you both let's start with the
observer um should we having a look at
uh that front page pictured there king
charles iii as uh he comes to the throne
starting the morning with the
formalities of that
proclamation christina
well i mean i think we're all reeling
actually it's all it all seems to be
happening so quickly that literally on
thursday afternoon the queen was our
monarch and now we have a new king and
the processes of state and constitution
have kicked in and he gave that
incredibly moving speech yesterday i i
would challenge anyone to watch that and
not have
had a tear while they watched it and
today it was the kind of almost
bureaucratic side of things although
that was also pretty ceremonial with
ex-prime ministers and uh and so on so
things are kicking in quite quickly
really and i think we're all adjusting
to the fact that charles is now our king
but i must say he hasn't put a foot
wrong
since this happened and i i think you
know not everybody has loved him forever
but i think everyone is feeling an
enormous amount of sympathy and support
for him at the moment and i certainly
feel
when he gave that speech yesterday i i
couldn't help thinking i'd be quite
critical of him in the past but i
couldn't help thinking we're in good
hands
martin do you echo that what did you
make very much so yeah actually funnily
enough i bumped into our postman this
morning and he said to me i've never
really thought much about charles never
really cared for him very much but i saw
his speech yesterday and i thought he
was absolutely magnificent and i think
that's the point i think he started so
brilliantly yesterday and and today as
well um this mixture of solemnity
and dignity but also the human touch all
the time you know talking about you know
his mother and you know love for his
mother and all of that and how he was
sharing in the nation's grief so i just
think it's been a wonderful combination
of of the solomon and the huma and the
human
and then today i'm really wanting to to
actually
get in touch with the people literally
physically yes out on the uh the streets
the walk about um
we saw people really wanting to to hear
from him and be close to him
and then you're almost tearing up that
was also incredibly moving the way that
he people wanted to kiss him and shake
his hand and he wanted i'm sure there
would have been i mean of course he has
security guards with him but nobody can
guarantee
absolute security at a time like this
but you know he is kind of fearless and
very much wanting to show that he's
one you know of the people as well as uh
sovereign but also as martin said i
think the emotional tone is very
interesting i think he is the queen as
we know was
known for stoicism and after the death
of princess diana she had to she felt
she was doing the right thing in
supporting her grandsons but you know
there was national anger at her lack of
emotion and she was kind of forced into
um a kind of
u-turn in a way she had to give this
public speech sort of saying how sad she
was about the death of diana and i think
prince charles king charles there we are
already king charles is wanting to
already establish that times have
changed and as a nation we are more in
tune with our emotions now and also
there are issues he knows that um the
prince of wales as i must now call him
william you know that he is very keen on
talking about mental health issues and
so on and i think it is part of a subtle
shift in that direction
let's move on to the express and they're
reporting on the the queen's wish coming
true for charles what what exactly are
they referring to well they're referring
to the fact that he's he's become now
the head of the commonwealth which he's
always wanted to be
and you know it's been his dream
apparently since he was a small child
and he visited malta so
you know it's a wonderful moment for him
i mean it's obviously a big challenge
and um but he seems determined and very
passionate about sort of doing his best
in that area so um yeah that's his wish
come true do you think rosina that we're
going to to see his role though as head
of the commonwealth change because of
various comments that he's made in
rwanda and the evolving commonwealth if
it even remains
i mean how can it not change how can it
not change it it already feels somewhat
anachronistic but uh but i know there is
there is still a lot of loyalty in in
you know a lot of the commonwealth for
the monarchy and um and i think we'll
just have to see but certainly the
political climate has changed and that
will be a huge challenge and
unfortunately for charles and i'm sure
he's intensely painfully aware of this
he does has so far not inspired and does
not generally inspire the kind of
adoration that the queen has done and i
think the queen was able to
override
so much of the the politics of things
simply through sheer force of her
personality i mean even i remember there
was footage of her first dance but i
can't remember whether it was the uh
king of ghana
who was it the guy
i think it was sorry the first dance
with the president kawanda was it was it
president
and and that was like you know the first
time a white queen has danced with a
black man in public and that was a huge
thing at the time and i think you know
she
she was um
she was so widely loved and and that she
was kind of and of course things were
very very different then i think that
will be a challenge for charles and
we'll see i i i think he has learnt so
much in his years of being sort of
probably too open about his political
views but i think he probably brings a
lot of wisdom to the role now
let's move on to the um telegraph i
think we can bring up
next uh reunited in sorrow the
brothers and their
wives together again in grief we read
that
uh the prince of wales got that one
correct um has actually extended the
olive branch
yes which i think has taken everyone
slightly by surprise today um
i was certainly surprised that they
appeared to have shared the same car to
uh
to the to the uh the great walk i i
cannot imagine the atmosphere in that
car actually to some extent because i
think it the the body language between
them did not seem particularly
comfortable on the walkabout
um and one wonders i mean
apparently it was it was william's idea
but i think it probably came from
charles initially and i think charles
kind of planted the seed of it yesterday
in his speech when he mentioned about
megan and harry making a life board and
all of that
um but it was a it was a it was a it was
something that i think a lot of the
crowd wanted to see
but it i think for them it felt like a
very kind of awkward moment
um
but let's face it this has to be
resolved and i think um efforts are
being made by william and by charles to
try and sort of resolve this situation
because i think the last thing that
charles needs in the early
months of his reign or years of his
reign is this sort of festering problem
in the pa you know it's sort of carrying
on
um so i think he he and william are both
determined in their own ways perhaps in
william's case through gritty teeth to
to actually sort of make this happen and
have this kind of
um
you know bring this thing together and
and make peace as it were christina do
you get the sense that that this is the
end of any feud if there was one no i
don't get that sense that it's the end
of a food but i feud but i think it will
i think that william has made a huge
effort and of course harry also i'm not
exactly sure what the power balance is
so whether harry would have to do what
his brother suggested i imagine
not but i think the thing is that um
harry's memoir is still looming and
there is enormous fear uh from
in the royal family about that and we
read today that um harry was told that
megan would not be welcome at the
queen's deathbed um presumably because
of things like her oprah interview and
uh
uh spotify podcast recordings and so on
i think the trouble is that their
business model for surviving
post-monarchy is predicated on them um
essentially moaning about the royal
family and their experience the royal
family and this would be a very very bad
time to be doing that so i don't know
what will happen on that front i don't
know whether the publication of the
memoir will be delayed and i think it
will be very hard to see that there will
be real and genuine reconciliation
between particularly charles well
actually all of them charles william and
harry if their memoir is truly explosive
and critical of them but we'll have to
see on that front yeah i think the
memoir is a really interesting point and
it feels as if
with the mood at the moment in the
country i think it would feel as if it
would make sense for him to delay that
because i just can imagine the
publication of it is going to be an
incredibly unpopular move given the
great wave of support for charles in the
in the country and obviously that all
the grief around the queen and
everything else i think the idea of
bringing that book out in was it
november i think it's quite it's sort of
quite imminent isn't it so
and i mean i think also from the
publisher's point of view do they really
want to be involved in that at this
stage yes sir remains to be seen whether
that will be delayed but what did you
make of the optics of the announcement
of the queen's death being made before
harry was able to get to burma
i just think it was yeah it was it was
unfortunate wasn't it but i mean
it was just the way it it was i mean you
know i i think uh
i don't think it was anything deliberate
there i mean you know it was it was just
the sort of timing were sort of off
really um it didn't look good that's for
sure um but
i think you know at times like that and
there was quite a bit of confusion
really i mean it was smoother
in some ways but it there was also
slight confusion people rushing up
trying to be there and obviously we know
that not everybody was there
um but that's the way these things sort
of unfold so
on to the uh sun let's take a look at
that of
the royals looking at
flowers um that's also on the walkabout
that they they went on there was also
the the other walkabout with other
members in balmoral um where you could
see that the family
was showing
much emotion and you know quite open
about their degree yeah well i think i
think the thing is that um it's not just
that you know the nation has lost a
queen she was absolutely adored by her
own family and i think she was
you know we saw generally uh in the
relatively emotionless side of her but i
think she was extremely funny i did have
the pleasure of meeting her twice and
and
i was actually just telling trevor
phillips um that uh
uh
the poet john agard um who later got the
queen's gold medal of poetry i was at a
party in buckingham palace in 2002
because i was helping to organize i was
running the poetry society helping to
organize a golden jubilee poetry
competition and the poet john agard was
there and the queen came up and talked
to andrew motion the then poet laureate
and me and john agard and he was
flirting with her and she was laughing
and she was just great fun and you think
gosh people don't really see you like
this and i think she was you know she
was she was funny she was witty she was
sharp obviously i barely knew her but i
mean i didn't know her i just met her
but people who knew her well um loved
her and she was very kind so they are
all and i think you know harry and
william were very close to their
grandmother and she will be deeply
deeply missed by her family and it's
difficult for them because they have to
they go through this private grief at a
time of great public grief and they have
to kind of balance that and that's quite
difficult yes very difficult for king
charles
taking on this mantle when
trying to to deal with with this grief
he's lost his his mother she was the
queen yeah she was his mother you know
you lose your mum i mean it's just you
know it's absolutely devastating i think
um and
yes she's having to go through that as
well i mean the interesting thing i
think in terms of the love that the the
the the children had the grandchildren
having the
for the queen came across when william
was talking about the fact that he had
this this amount of time with the queen
you know he was grateful for that amount
of time and then mentioned that kate had
had this amount of time and it was
almost like you know it was precious i
mean obviously she's been old
she's been old for a while and you know
the kind of shadow of what happened on
thursday has been there for a while and
i think that all of those years for
those precious years and i think the
fact that william immediately sort of
reflected on that just showed how valued
those were and how close they were they
are an incredibly close family
we're just going to move away from uh
the story today here and move to um
ukraine to finish off with uh the sunday
times and uh the observer covering this
story and this is the
the pushback from ukraine it seems as if
fortunes are are turning
well
at the moment but it's been i think
they've taken the most territory they've
since march which is absolutely
wonderful news and they've taken i think
kupienskan isium up in the northeast and
kobiansk is particularly important
because it's a supply
route for
russian soldiers in the
in the uh to the east so
it looks great i mean i think we hardly
dare breathe when it comes to ukraine
because putin will do absolutely
anything and he is prepared to
feed every
russian male in the country through the
meat grinder of his horrible horrible
operation but certainly it sounds as
though they've taken nearly a thousand
square miles of territory which is
phenomenal so long may it last and let's
hope they do succeed in taking back here
son and and kharkiv and um and you know
that
this is the beginning of the end but i
have to say i i think there's a long way
to go on it
christina and martin thank you very much
for the moment we have run out of time